my hero academia heroes rising a new
movie is coming out we just shot a
reaction for Hunter hunter saw this on
ing n's website the official English dub
trailer for my hero academia Heroes
rising now the contemplation comes like
this because we do stream Laurie Segall
for the timecode and reaction highlights
included at our patreon for my hero
academia at the moment we're only a
couple episodes behind on season 4 go
check us out our patreon page are there
because the dilemma is do we watch this
in the theatres and enjoy it as fans of
my hero academia or do we wait for it to
be available online so we can record a
reaction for it you guys let us know in
the comments below
meantime go check out our reactions over
at patreon let's do this
[Music]
Oh No paka coma Toria the hero work
recommendation you'll be stationed here
on now who island in southern Japan
while you're there we'll be completely
on your own no teachers to help you or
throws to back you up it's all gonna go
wrong
[Music]
all the way what kind of hero would you
want to be we want to be a super strong
one Paquito
villain oh come on there are these
villains on this island oh oh soon
[Music]
[Music]
Wow
oh sweet we can go see it in both
version at the same time record
reactions in the theater and get thrown
out and banned be pretty sweet too
watching the theatres it would be all
right guys before we talk about this
like we mentioned had a patreon we
covered my hero academia there shows you
to watch along for and those shows are
agents of shield stranger things season
3 Gotham hunting a Hell House Season 1
Cobra Kai season 2 and the shows where
we have the option for watch along or
reaction highlights included those shows
are Hunter hunter one punch man Code
Geass Death Note
attack on Titan Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood supernatural my hero
academia but we also covered the last
movie as well so that's what the
constant conflict comes in do we cover
it or do we watch the theaters keep this
chained up so my question is though is
this gonna be something that takes place
like after season 4 I mean it should be
something essential where it's segways
in the season 5 other spoilers for
season 5 involved in this you know say
if we showed up on the release date
being a couple episodes behind when we
spoil or be very lost yeah yeah I mean
we haven't heard the mangas but I heard
very brief things about this 9 character
supposedly has multiple quirks don't
know what any of them are but all I know
is this when a villain has a mask on he
always talks on this lower I just heard
right
that's why we gotta subvert expectations
whenever we make a superhero movie make
like a really charter guy yeah won't
shut up it's hard to understand but
still keeping it up I mean you had the
Yakuza in season 4 he's still got the
league of villains but were at in the
show and now you got this other gang of
villains I love whenever they decided to
any anime show i watch whatever we're
gonna take a trip always goes wrong
yeah don't take the trip what I'm hoping
for from this movie though is in the
last one not everyone truly got a chance
to really shine based off of here the
fehb you especially you don't have all
my with his powers or any of the
teachers anyway exactly this could be
something where although the students
get it
chance to really shine and get a chance
to really demonstrate their powers and
it looks like baku go and Medora are
gonna be doing a lot of working together
here o which excites me because they're
always at odds and when they work
together it's it's rare but always cool
archer de vanilla now they're gonna have
a common goal I love that using one for
all that 100% oh yes Yahoo Rosa looks
like she gets a lot - a lot of time to
shine in this movie - yeah it looks like
she had like Canon hey whatever and then
eat uh more screen time here than he has
an all season four so far first half of
this movie when things are normal and
there's on the island I have to imagine
Ito will go nuts just trying to keep
people in line at or after you've just
eaten don't swim too soon build that Sam
Cassell better I hope that my hero wraps
on those planes briefly here in the
trailer plays in the finale when they're
winning I hope that's the the song that
goes over the whole keeps coming in
throughout the film yeah and not even
over the credits yeah I think they
should do a pokerap because there's so
many characters with so many
corresponding hero names it would be
perfect for a tie-in novelty song I'm
just saying but interesting about this
show is they've established well early
on in the first few seasons there's like
over 80% of the population has quirks so
the people who are quirk lists are
actually the minority yes in this world
they've established yet when they go to
and I noticed there's someone with a
cork and then someone who's a hero I get
that just when they go to this island
and they're like we're the only heroes
here but shouldn't on average 80 percent
of the peace I leave a clue
certification so seriously and then
nobody even dares to choose their quirk
outside they can't even fight you know
but yeah like if something goes down you
would think that people would just need
to do it and defend themselves and the
people around now there's supposed to be
a lot more movies to come after this one
apparently that excites me because the
last movie two heroes I thought was
great and it's more than just some
extended episode like they are they do
it felt like a real movie the animation
did feel incredibly cinematic which is
pretty hard to top considering how
especially at the way house season 4 has
been
animated yeah like that's something that
we've absolutely loved about this latest
season it's been it's taking a much
darker approach for the most part the
way they play with structuring their
episodes and the types of visuals they
infuse have been so rewarding and
different for the series overall I don't
know who's directing this movie but I'm
hoping they do take a few cues to have
some liberties with really given us some
truly impactful cinematic moments
especially in its grand finale that
undoubtedly they're gonna have that's
why I actually am more drawn to the idea
of watching this on the big screen
yeah but I just want to make for a real
reaction if we reacted to it that's the
conflict well maybe if we just don't
look at any footage from it until it
drops on just like forget and then we
can do a fresh reaction yeah I mean this
looks like it's definitely gonna have a
lot of huge scale stuff I feel like
anytime you get a movie spin-off from an
action-oriented anime action just goes
that much more hog-wild in the movie
version I'm interested to see where this
is gonna fall because to Heroes was
largely in the past right so it makes
sense as to how you can have that movie
running subs you know concurrently with
the show this on the other hand I'm
curious as to where and how it fits in
because it's all of our heroes all of
our class 1-a students true having to
throw down in a what seems to be a
situation that would you'd think affect
the show itself of course yeah so that's
what makes me hugely curious about this
and just the notion that literally no
one else of authority is on this island
yeah that's the one piece of the setup
I'm like really like you're just gonna
let the kids be the law on this island
and all the people who are here are
aware of that and they're okay with that
- a man's of anything were to happen
well dude they want to graduate this is
just part of their lesson maybe this is
all just a big training program yeah
maybe that's what real villains after
all just heroes who were pretending to
be villains you know I just realized
he's going 100 percent in here without
eerie I know I know
that's dangerous but wait in the show
didn't you go a thousand percent is that
what he did I don't know that episode I
think was titled like a thousand percent
forever or so the exam still so you know
but yeah without earring like he's gonna
damage something going on
% no yeah Doria man I'll have to get
some kisses from that old lady yes yes
that'll be the post-credits sees her
kissing his entire body and then it
turns in system softcore jazz music and
you know what goes on from there and
then he sues because that is illegal
alright guys well what did you think of
this trailer are you excited for this
movie is it playing in your state town
country leave a comment below if it's
not let us know unleash your anger in
the comment boxes subscribe click the
notification bell make sure to check us
on patreon for all them goodies and hey
let's end this without gene Jeter I'm a
boy
guys go check out gene Jeter's Instagram
who shared on our community page photos
of beautiful men and women and I asked
him directly gene how many of these
girls have you you know done the
hanky-panky with and he has said none
Greg I am a professional why would you
insinuate such a thing and I'm like gene
come on man yo you're a good-looking
dude you're charming that make sure the
girls would love to do stuff with you
and he said Greg back off you're being
inappropriate right now I might
seriously I'm pledge if you keep going
like gene I'm just trying to tell you
man that if you wanted to Greg that's it
I'm gonna expose you to the world
the next shout out you give you're gonna
tell everyone about this conversation so
they can know how much of a creep you
are and how you probably treat women a
real-life whoa
gene I don't want to do that man that's
just gonna make me look bad and it's not
true I was just making light of the fact
that yeah these hot girls are your
Instagram no next shout-out you're gonna
tell them the truth
so that's gene Jeter for you guys I felt
like I was there for this whole
conversation just now gene you know take
it easy on my man's right here all right
and keep sending me those pictures of
yourself with all the girls